so this is a hangout on air one that's
created just for a discussion between
myself and zachary taylor who has a lot
of interesting ideas and questions about
the connection between philosophy and
video games & Sons video games are such
an important part for not just you know
the current generation college students
and everybody younger but but also my
generation there's such an important
part of life and since I get get more
and more complicated and sophisticated
every year to where you can't even tell
you know sometimes whether a trailers
for a video gamer for a movie this is a
really important topic I think so we've
got a bunch of different points to to
chat about and that's all this really is
just a chat between somebody who
specializes in philosophy and somebody
specializes in game design and thinking
about how these things could be
connected up in more meaningful ways so
that's my sort of some of it what what
do you what's your take on what we're
doing here I'm about the same a friendly
chat regarding two fields that often
don't have the connection they really
should all right so do you want to work
with the topics that I sent you by email
them that that list of topics one of
which kind of requires you to do a
little legwork because I don't have much
to say about the third one no worries um
say we just wing it and work those as a
base first of all I think the easiest
thing phones talk about would be the way
video games can interact with education
teaching in general and teaching a
philosophy specifically okay well let's
start with the general then you know
when we get past like the K through 12
teacher your kid how to do better math
and that sort of thing games how do we
you know there's also sort of a stigma
attached to educational games that
they're not really fun or engaging
they're too didactic how do you get past
that um I think a lot of the problem
with that is
a lot of educational games try to
approach it from like a trivia kind of
way they try to teach you memorization
of facts and they try to make it fun and
I think that's I mean that has its use
but I think it's more effective to take
a tangential approach try to get the
person engaged into it make them
interested and then let them do the
legwork themself and because with with
the internet now we have the Library of
Alexandria at our fingertips yeah you
just got to get the person into it okay
so this is that question of what games
can offer in terms of Education that
that the way we typically do it you know
15 week semesters classrooms even even
online education can't can't really do
and and you know I think one of the huge
advantages is you can get people to
spend a lot of time in a game that's
harder to get them to spend as much time
working through the material outside of
class even if you set up like a really
great online course shell to supplement
what you're doing it's it's it's all
over the map whereas if you can get
people playing a game there's the chance
that they'll spend too much time on it
but you know you can you can get them to
just spend quite a bit more time on on
principles or basic ideas and from an
outsider's view that seems like the
entire art of teaching is engagement is
getting them engaged enough to want to
learn and that's what video games
specialize in yeah I'd say you're right
about that there's there's been a shift
they call it learner-centered education
and there's been a shift away from just
understanding what we do is imparting
content to seeing that what we do has to
meet the learners where they are and
then bring them to the to the content
sometimes it goes a little bit too far
to the we're going to just entertain
them make it as fun as possible and then
you don't get as much of the the actual
content as you need and that could be a
real problem for philosophy because you
know the stuff that were work
trying to teach first we're at a
disadvantage here in the states anyway
because we don't do philosophy in any
meaningful way in K through 12 whereas
you know in France depending on what
you're studying in Britain some of the
other curricula like in Portugal it's
you know grades 10 and 11 they they have
a philosophy component we don't have
anything like that so we can't build on
a basis that you know we can presuppose
and then we're trying to you know get
usually 18 19 20 year-olds to engage
with pretty abstract high level stuff
instead and stuff that hasn't had been a
part of their life or really their
culture yeah that's that's a big point
too I mean if you can show them how like
with ethics if you can show them how
some of the discussions it had about
high school bullying or things like that
actually fit into what you're talking
about then you can get some mileage out
of that but boy you know I I think when
I was just out of grad school was an
awful teacher I was because I expected
everybody to be as interested in in
these texts and thinkers and problems as
I was a grad student of course nobody is
and so yeah it took a long time to get
what they call learner-centered so the
games can can do that you think I think
they can at least for some people i
don't think anything's ever universal
but i think it's uh of course i'm saying
it should be supplemental it definitely
not replace anything entirely um
there'll always be room for the teacher
there always be room for the human
contact I think it's a vital even so let
me push this done in in a long line that
I had in the notes in a really rich game
environment you've got malt you know a
lot of players and how would you bring
in teachers into that that environment
you know I mean you imagine like
Minecraft you could you could have like
you know you build yourself you know
virtual
but then that would be kind of boring
really yeah it just it just be school
with a nice paint job yeah which I think
we have to take an entirely different
approach that the game itself almost has
to become the teacher design of it has
to encourage people to approach things
in new ways so how would that work in
terms of you know like say critical
thinking or ethics those are two the big
areas and philosophy that often bleed
over into to other areas um there's a
couple games coming to mind papers
please is very popular one in which you
have to make ethical decisions balancing
your family's livelihood and these
people who may get killed um but
obviously there's still there's limited
agency in that the the effects there's
still a game um on the topic of
multiplayer games things like eve online
I don't know if you're familiar with it
now unfortunately I had too much about
income for games it's it's a sandbox
game in which millions of people play or
50,000 people or so play and it's one
big world and pretty much anything is
allowed within the context of the game
you can kill other people you can rob
them you can scam them people have wars
over resources there's a full economy
and I think if you have the proper
metrics you can learn a lot from it
study it and then the game itself can
introduce things subtly to see how
people react and then people can learn
from that of course it all had there's
also responsibility of the person
learning to actively try to learn so
yeah so when you say introduce things
subtly do you mean in some way you could
channel somebody if we have a particular
moral theory like say utilitarianism
which if you want to boil it down so
something along the lines of what's
what's good is what works out best for
most people and even if it harms
few people in the process so long as
most people's outcomes are better that's
the thing you should do how would you
how would you subtly build that in so
that people would be learning about that
or being guided in that way I mean you
could eat it like I suppose you could
have scenarios where they have to decide
that sort of thing but that doesn't seem
very subtle yeah well I say say the
designers introduced a vital resource
something your character needs to live
um same water I'm kind of foods better
let's say food now you can create more
food but there is a limited supply and
the gamers could just by changing a few
variables or not the gamers I'm sorry
the designers changing few variables
make it so it's not possible to produce
enough food for every player this would
the higher echelons of the players the
people who run the Guild's the
corporation's the whatever the system is
would then have to make decisions based
on obvious that's very limited but we'd
have to make decisions on distributing
and although that may be more useful for
a sociological perspective of research
well I think it would also be very
beneficial to the players figuring out
that dilemma in a semi real way which is
its own existential discussion is the am
ia real what I want to get but you know
it seems like so long as you can provoke
two things you've got enough reality
that that it could work for for learning
something about ethics you need it to
mimic thought processes and I don't see
that as being too difficult you know you
can even build that in very explicitly
and then you have to have people feeling
the weight of these kind of problems you
know being emotionally engaged the key
thing the key thing because the
multiplayer game your actions have
effect on other people not just the game
yeah I'm there anything that really give
you feedback like hey you're a jerk or
you're a great guy that sort of thing
right all right they might be able to
overthrow you or hunt you down or
whatever however the game works that can
be built in it can be consequences for
your actions okay I think that it also
lets people roleplay kinda you can see
okay there's people running around
killing other people you you can analyze
that you really don't see that day to
day I mean hopefully if they on your
neighborhood but but it lets you lets
you interact with people in a way you
wouldn't normally you know you know one
of the arguments that people want to
restrict gaining usually make is these
are desensitizing the teaching ad last
the two people who otherwise wouldn't
think you know of doing such horrible
things to each other but it seems like
you could steer games in the opposite
direction to where you know essentially
what we're talking about is teaching
people how to be empathetic how did how
do you know grasp what's what's good in
people's actions what's bad in people's
actions why it's harmful you know that
sort of thing I think the greatest power
games have as an art form as a teaching
mechanism is the ability to grant
perspective and ways other forms can't
to put you in the shoes of someone not
just let you view someone who's in a
different position yeah is it possible
with where we are currently I mean I
know that people create videos of you
know their own gaming experience and
sometimes their tutorials or sometimes
they're hey look at how cool this is but
is it possible to actually like see
things in any of the games that are out
let's say you and I were both playing a
game and I and you gave me permission to
sort of like be inside of your head and
see what your you're up to and then say
vote on it you're doing good things
you're doing bad things you should do
this sort of thing you shouldn't do that
sort of thing is that I mean I know that
that's going to be possible
futures that where we are called well
two things on that the first is that is
kind of possible through streaming
people stream their gameplay and other
people comment on it watch it chat with
the person playing stuff like that
that's up to the person how much input
they take but the other thing is have
you heard of twitch plays Pokemon by
ABBA um it was fairly recent that
happened I think there's another one
going on it's essentially remember the
old pokemon games Vegas yeah well they
took one of the old ones one of the
original ones and they made an emulator
for it on a computer and then they
played the game with like 50,000 people
all playing at once one game and they
played democratically huh like they
would all every 10 seconds it would take
if everyone typed up if the majority of
people typed up every 10 seconds it
would move up or do they beat the game
they beat the game it took from 16 days
but they beat the game democratically
let sit right with that that's
interesting because you know a lot of
times doing actions by committee doesn't
always work out so well yeah so you have
to have a bunch of people I think that
that are all sort of you know they all
have the same aims in mind like beating
the game you know and that's good well
you could have had a bunch of people in
there who just said let's just screw
around with this is just possible you
know you'd have to have some way to to
they supposed to read that out so you
cut out on me it was going to say I
think you'd have to have some way to
weed out but there wasn't it there was
people there's lots of people like that
yeah there was a lot of people who need
wanted to cause trouble and it is
interesting that is interesting to see
how that yeah is a very interesting
process the whole thing is very very
good research material I think for many
things yeah you know do you this is sort
of like a one of those sort of big
picture you know
sci-fi possibly utopia dystopia kind of
questions but you know the games are
getting extremely complex you know and
and the environments are getting richer
and richer and richer and more more
expansive and a lot of people are
spending a lot of time online or you
know involved in playing these games the
interfaces are also getting better and
better and better so do you see this is
leading towards you know within within
our lifetime situations where people are
just going to be plugged into games more
often than they are to to you know face
to face environments or what I mean
onset I think that's already true for
some people actually i personally know
people who are like that who are they
spend at least 10 hours a day playing a
video game particularly these online
ones and are still interacting with
people but obviously it's not the same
well I wonder um you know you think that
is the technology gets better and better
and better like think about this
interface right now you know I can see
you in this this sort of limited frame
and so long as we stay within the screen
we're okay we're not trying to do
anything particularly you know that
involves running or jumping or fighting
or digging or things like that but this
stuff is going to get better and better
and better and this is a real
interaction right now we're exchanging
ideas you know wouldn't it wouldn't it
be possible to have this sort of thing
within the structure of a game oh
absolutely I've some of the best friends
I've ever made we're through a game I've
never I have no idea what they look like
x is the other avatars yeah and just
because within those worlds you have a
certain amount of an amenity and you can
people are much more willing to just
express themselves and be who they are
without fear of judgement oh so it's
easier to make deeper friendships I
think in a way i wonder if that sort of
anonymity
be useful you know like I'll teach a
mind ethics class with 25 people over
say a 10-week period and now imagine
they had an environment in which they
could you know put around and do good
things or do bad things see consequences
come about you know have people say
you're doing the wrong thing here's why
you know or your that was a good thing
to do but it but it had that anonymity
that would probably afford them you know
quite a bit more more freedom especially
as students because I find a lot of my
students are rather shy you know when it
comes to trying on trying out ideas big
ideas you know I should be this kind of
person I should I should do this sort of
thing you know their logistics or just
expressing the ideas they already hold
because they don't know if that's
acceptable within the majority yeah so I
think I think it has a lot of power both
good and bad everything of course can go
both ways except know how we regulate
and how we deal with it personally but
um there was another thing I want to
talk about regarding perspective and it
had to do with the morals and to be
specific cons kind of idea of the
categorical good okay I I had a break
thought about what if you had a game
where you just whatever the plot of the
game is but you make choices but the
society in which the game takes place is
the exact opposite of what we would
think of as the cat the contemporary
categorical good the killing is good
moral charity is bad ok so it's see how
players operate within a world that's
been flipped it upside down that would
be yeah that would be pretty interesting
it wouldn't be quite the same thing as
the thought experiments that can't
carries out where he says you know if
you want to figure out whether killing
somebody with no provocation is against
your your duty or compatible with duty
universalize it and say every night not
only everybody can or it's good but
everybody shall so imagine a world in
which any
just you know whenever they feel like it
kills somebody else and pretty soon you
don't have the world at all that's
that's the sort of thought process that
he does or with being good to other
people like what you're calling charity
he calls benevolence do we do we help
other people out or do we say screw them
you know imagine a world in which nobody
ever helps anybody with anything ah
that's that's really funny because I've
put games words like that yeah I don't
doubt it but it's uh so that can be
really useful actually to to depict you
know you create the the game environment
and you tell people okay this is what
you have to do here's the rules of the
game here's here's the goal try to kill
as many people as possible very quickly
you don't have you don't know you just
have you know a few people left you
don't have a world I would it play out
with them nobody helps anybody else I
mean I can picture I can picture that
for you know sandbox games like
Minecraft how they play out in terms of
other games well I think a part of that
is how would you enforce that yeah see
with cons what you're carrying to figure
out whether it's right or wrong you're
actually carrying out this thought
experiment in which not only everybody
can act that way everybody's supposed to
act that way everybody does act that way
and then if it leads to some sort of
absurd conclusion you say ya see that
can't possibly be do the right thing but
it would be very interesting to like
build it in and say well you don't have
to act this way but expect everybody
else to do it and you you're only going
to get points if you do it this way or
however you want to you know freighters
there's a video game called Daisy it's a
zombie apocalypse survival okay and your
character when he dies is dead you have
to make a new character okay I'm a death
and it's a survival game you have to
monitor like you can't lose too much
blood you get hungry you get thirsty
there's very limited ammo
Oh things like this and it's interesting
you find there's two two types of
players there's more than two types but
there's two general actors the bandits
and whatever the non bandits would be a
bandage will just kill people on site
take their stuff go then you have other
people who will hold you up they'll come
up with a gun and say drop all your gear
walk away yeah and it's two very
different approaches but with the same
outcome well kind of different outcome
you know what I mean the same intention
get their stuff so you can survive yeah
and then you have people grouping
together they have people fighting and
it's a very interesting little microcosm
of human interaction with no with
consequences but limited consequences
yeah as if you just kill someone you're
still screwing that person ever you just
it but you didn't really kill them use
ruined 20 hours of their life yeah but
it is yeah that's that's taking
something I suppose you know it's it's
sort of like robbing them of an
investment you know uh you know it's you
know it's gonna piss them off you know
you probably didn't have to do it yeah
but it might have been slightly safer
than saying okay drop your stuff because
then maybe they would have pulled
something so there's these little
decisions you have to make risk analysis
yeah so you know let me ask you about
one of the topics that i had in in the
notes you know when we're talking about
ethics we have a number of different
moral theories and i can see how some of
them could could be interjected into a
game world very easily like egoism you
know i have just everyone takes care of
themselves and if you want to associate
with other other people it should only
be when it's advantageous to you that
that sort of thing I would dare say
that's the prevailing more thing well
yeah and and you made a good case for
how utilitarianism might be brought into
a game and I think we could you know we
could figure out how how contient ethics
or other day aunt illogical ethics could
be brought in one of the one of the
areas that I'm real
interested in is is virtue ethics where
we're talking about the development of a
person's character and good traits and
removal of bad traits over time and
that's a little harder to to see how you
would I could build that into to a game
I mean there's there's clearly some some
traits that would be easier to to do
that way like fairness you know you can
you tell whether somebody's behaving in
a fair way over time maybe because
you're in you're in an association with
them or honesty or courage you know
courage is one I think would be very
easy with games because most games tend
to revolve around conflict so but it's
it's harder to see how these games could
could help a person develop good
character maybe maybe what it would take
would be having some people in the game
saying here's how you know here's here's
how you ought to act you ought to learn
how to be generous you're really a
stingy guy you know and I don't really
like that and overtime work you know
there is a game company called Bioware I
think they're Canadian damn they've
honestly kind of been making the same
game for 10 years we're good but but
with different settings and they improve
upon it the system they have every time
and essentially what they're talking
about is what you're talking about you
play a character who has choices you can
you have your end goal there's a main
storyline but how you interact with the
world is up to you you can be good you
can be bad you can be pragmatic you can
be charitable whatever and you have
party members who all have their own
personal opinions and you choose we
bring with you they comment on your
actions Oh things like this and it's
it's when I was young that was a big
factor for me uh I remember one of them
knights of the old republic as a star
wars game one of the main characters she
is absolutely pragmatic she's neutral
she
views everything perfectly like I
remember and I'm ranting on about this a
little bit but one particular scene a
beggar comes up to you and he asked for
some money now you can either a give him
some money and he'll thank you walk away
it just scold you for it so say you gave
him money but now you made him weaker by
doing so and their shows a little
cutscene of that guy going and she says
now that he has something that he didn't
earn other people want to take it from
him you've just bread resentment is you
see a cut scene of a guy bugging him on
the flip side you cannot give him money
and she'll scold you still and she'll
say that what you've done is now because
the way you say no to him is kind of a
dickish way to do it yeah get out of
here you scum and she says now you've
just bread um anger in him and he goes
and he mopes someone and like this these
little things and they make you look at
it like well what should I have done
yeah and I think it's really useful I
think their approach of it is very good
that's one of those which is the lesser
of the two evils kepta you have to pick
yeah so these characters are all non
player characters that are coming along
for the ride and chiding you or
counseling you or keeping track of what
you're doing in these game right yeah
they have their own personal viewpoints
it would be interesting to have a
mixture between those because those are
built in by the game designers and then
have the possibility of other people
sort of coming along for the ride and
saying well you really shouldn't have
done that because you know here's here's
what's likely to result from that or
that was a really good thing that you
did and here's you may not have thought
of it but here's here's why I think the
good Oncenter the most interesting
dialogue of those games comes when you
have to party members usually can only
bring two at a time if to party members
who disagree and then they have a little
three or four line disagreement about
what you did why it was good white
bad yeah now that's that's an important
point because you know one of the things
that we do know about moral development
is that it doesn't take place just
through like you know reading the script
and then applying it over and over and
over again it happens oftentimes through
through conflicts of perspectives and
through sometimes you know through doing
the wrong thing somebody coming along
saying hey jackass knock that off here's
why what you did is bad and then you
know getting upset about it and arguing
with them and then and then you know
afterwards thinking about it and saying
no actually they were right i need to
you need to quit behaving that way and
so this this the conflict of
perspectives and having to explain your
your perspective why is this the good
thing to do why is this the bad thing to
do that that's very important for for
moral development so and that that seems
like it's you know it's not an
impossible thing to build in but it
seems like a hard thing to to imagine
how you you build it in with the sort of
flexibility that you you want on these
but I suppose you know this would be an
interesting area of to think about in
terms of a I you know we usually I had
good I think I think I know you're going
to go with that and I had a thought of
just off the top of my head of how this
could be implemented within a classroom
say you have a student obviously you
have more than one student but let's
just say for this one student he's
playing the game I probably a more
simplified version but he has to make
these kind of decisions and he makes the
decision and then you can ask him why
did you make that decision yeah and then
he has to give you or you could even do
a paper of it like detail his where he
went through the game and you have
preset points why did you do this why
did you do that how did you resolve this
conflict why and even and you just make
them think about it okay well why did I
do that yeah and then give them more
insight into their own processes yeah I
think that that's a very important part
that we often have to leave that you
know when we try to teach we have to
pass
can so much when we run through it so
quickly our students are all taking five
or six classes at a time and you know
trying to do all the other things that
students do anyway like have a social
life and stay in touch with their family
a lot of net jobs and so a lot of times
we're teaching ethics that that personal
imaginative connection just drops out
because we you know we say well what
should a person do in this case but
that's not the same thing as my actually
saying I ought to do this in this case
or I'm going to choose this and then see
what the the consequences are it's
lacking that that personal connection
and games would be a great way in which
you know like you said as a supplement
we could we could train people to not
not in the sense of like you know
necessarily making them see things this
way or this way but but open their their
eyes so they can have more perspective
on it if nothing else give them more
insight to how they already look at
things yeah but give them something a
base to work from yeah yeah often thing
also go ahead no go ahead alright yeah
in an academic situation that I've never
been to college so I really don't know
if that well but I imagine an academic
situation for these kind of theoretical
questions it's hard to give that much
context to the dilemma well the more
that you do the two dangers with that
are the more context that you give the
more the dilemma starts to resolve
itself sort of like automatically you
know it becomes a no-brainer or it
starts getting bogged down in all sorts
of fifth ends well if this is the case
then you know or if you value this then
then you should do this and the students
start start disagreeing about that so
yeah you're right you have to keep cases
fairly generic in order to be able to
talk about them in class what I what I
usually do is I handle it through papers
that i have my stew
right where they'll have a concept from
in LC Plato's Republic or Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics and they have to tell
me about the concept first and then they
apply it to something in their own life
some experience they had and then you a
lot of interesting personal stuff comes
out there's that that application there
sometimes I tell me extremely personal
things in writing I think that's good
though I think once you make something
personal it sticks a lot better yeah
it's right it cements it for you it
changes because you start applying it to
now your personal life you start
applying it to more things and well
that's that's really the whole goal I
mean yeah well you know the other thing
is to when we're in schools where we
actually teach ethics because a lot of
colleges and universities it's not even
required that you take an ethics class
at all but in the in the places where we
do teach it it's just a semester and you
know at any given time that you're
talking to students in class about
two-thirds of them are not really paying
close attention to what you're saying
this is just what the attention studies
tell us and I know this is the case
because when I go to conferences I'm not
paying attention half the time to look
at speakers extang then somebody who's
trained to pay attention you know so so
I don't begrudge them you know their
their lack of attention but it means
that we get you know two and a half
hours of face time with them a week and
then you know we can maybe get them to
spend about five to eight hours at best
outside of class doing doing reading or
homework or been watching videos or
thinking about things unless we unless
we find some way to you know really get
that material the stick one semester is
not going to do a hell of a lot for them
you know we look at it like two three
semesters later and they forgotten most
of what we thought oh it's it's just how
we interact with the rest of our species
it's not that important I mean yeah
but if you know if ethics really matters
and part of the goal is to get people at
least further along the path towards
towards where they want to be at least
give them the tools today can figure out
where they want to be yeah then you know
we should we should be using the the
best means that are available to us you
know right right tool for the right job
yeah things that'll get get the the
content to really stick with them I
think a big thing of is I think to be a
really great teacher you have to have
some of the same talents to say a
stand-up comedian right after you have
to be an entertainer you really have to
get the people listening to you and
you're right that cat you need a captive
audience and example like that yeah it's
it's amazing most of my peers I've
noticed over the years think that most
people think of great teachers in
academia I'm not sure why maybe because
their students tell them they are
something like that and they're not
smart enough to realize that students
will you know make stuff up like you're
a great teacher and you go into their
classroom and you're like boy I wouldn't
take a class with this guy you know
Aristotle actually noticed this he talks
about this in the rhetoric he said all
teaching requires some degree of
persuasion and persuasion can't be done
without like holding people's attention
making it interesting you said even
mathematics you have to you have to
involve some persuasion I would think
especially mathematics but but yeah it
alone and I think I think video games it
as well as other art forms can fill that
role nicely or help that roll nicely ya
know one of the things that I I mean I
don't have really anything to say about
this but you wanted to talk about it was
the infancy of video games
development as an art form where do you
see me or hear in your you know deep in
this stuff right at the heart of it
where do you see this stuff going um I
mean predictions are always difficult
but I really don't have the proper data
or mental capacity for such but my
personal opinion um it's hard to say I
think there will be some advancement of
escapism there will people be people who
just get deeper and deeper into that
that becomes their life um I'm not gonna
say whether that's good or bad that's
its own discussion um I think I honestly
think MMOs massively multiplayer online
games in particular are going to push
forward the progress of mind uploading
technology if that is a feasible thing
yeah um I think I think there's a drive
for that within that environment but as
for games itself I hope they will grow
and become more complex and deep I mean
it just remember if we only had 30 or 40
years of books to read we wouldn't have
that many great books yeah so you're
saying it good well it's totes what
you're saying or with the analogy is
that the more games that we have out
there is sort of trial runs you know and
raw material things we're going to refer
back to eventually down the line that's
what's going to allow designers people
who are not only you know consuming
games as players and stuff like that but
actually thinking about sort of like the
way that a novelist what a novelist
reads a novel they they read it for
entertainment but they're also like
saying oh man that was a great plot
twist I got it I got to do that next
time or here's how I would have done
that better so designers would be doing
that with with the games that are the
body of work so far yeah and it it can
be hard to tell people that you're
playing a game for research they're like
oh okay shooter like no really I don't
even want to play
game but this game had a this game
created or genre I need to play it so
also there's because it is so new a lot
of people make video games like they're
trying to make a film or a book they're
not making it like they're making a game
and there that there's a residue of that
still coming off it's very strong um
especially with writing with video game
riding video game writings much
different than book writing or Philbrick
that's what leads to the sort of games
where it's almost like those will choose
your old adventure books are you gonna
pick a B or C and then it shows you have
in yet you know you picked a here's what
happens that sort of thing yeah and I
think video games are almost kind of an
extension of that kind of it's a much
better much more open-ended extension of
that way of thinking books really
weren't that good at it I mean that's up
to personal taste I really didn't enjoy
those kind of books that much yeah we
had to flip around a lot you know and
then yeah you'd actually like keep your
thumb I'm what they first came out you
put your thumb you know in the previous
one cuz you might you might want to go
back to it did you yeah the wrong lisha
you're not gonna just stop playing the
stop reading the book because you died
early oh I ran into something and it
killed me okay i'm done with a book
that's that's not how it works but well
I mean maybe it's up to the person I
guess but yeah I think games are an
extension of that and people are still
figuring out how to write a story within
that kind of medium you know a lot of
the the interactive I guess we can call
them games that are being done with
ethics are like that like choose your
own adventure books but I was talking to
some of the ROTC candidates at my
college and they were talking about this
this game with the army is using where
it will show us scenario and you know
it's sort of like a video playing and
then it'll say what should you do and
they have to the entire squad or the
entire platoon has to vote a B C or D
and then depending on what the pic it
does exactly that
choose-your-own-adventure thing it
it shows you that and says oh you know
you blew up the church full of people
that was a bad thing to do you know
long-drawn decision or you know you
managed to save these people but you
lost Jeff your squad not such a great
thing yeah but it's it is so still
restricted you know it's there these
these what would you call them it's sort
of like a you know a tree sort of idea
with with the branching off it's not
open-ended like you're talking about and
that open-endedness is something that I
would love to see ethics being able to
get incorporated into you know net open
open-ended can be difficult and video
game because for every decision the
player can make you have to make that
decision you have to make the outcome
yeah I have to unless you get you have
to start getting really clever with it
and it's it's a difficult it's a it's an
obstacle the industry is tackling
figuring out how to make a truly open
ended game hmm so let me ask you another
point going back to one of the things I
wanted to sort of tap your your your
imagination and your expertise about
when we're thinking about ethics one of
the things for a game world to be usable
for for teaching purposes we would need
one in where in which consequences and
the consistency of a person in their
behavior would matter and not just in an
individual situation but they would
continue to matter through the game and
I think one way in which this has been
dealt with in some games is by having
something like a you know reputation
number and here i'm not actually like
talking about because my experience
isn't so much with my first person
shooter games or things like that but
like a strategic you know forex types of
games where you know I keep screwing
people over or other other you know
cultures over you start to get a bad
reputation there there's sort of a
consequence to bad actions
you think that you'd need something like
that something like something that
corresponds to the role of social
approval you know or disapproval that
would continue through that would be a
motivating consequence right there
should be a factor in decisions you make
yeah I going to am I going to attack
this person well hold on let me look let
me these people won't like it these
people will well i don't i'm not sure if
I like these people can I trust these
people that kind of stuff is that we
talking about that would be yeah I know
that would be sort of a subdivision of
it um do you go around you know
attacking people just at random you'd
think that would be construed as a bad
thing do you you know step into
situations to uh help out people who are
being attacked who are otherwise you
know good people that can't take care of
themselves you that you think that would
be construed as a a good thing yeah and
there are two hearken back to the genre
I was talking about before the sandbox
MMO games um there's often situations
where you have groups of players who
form guilds clans corporations whatever
the game is and often there are there
are people who become known within the
society of the game a new players and
then there are people going hunt those
maniacs because it's the right thing to
do because they want to protect new
players or you have if you go and kill
the wrong person well now you have an
entire guild who once once your head
yeah and they're just they're going to
brief you they're going to kill you
every time they see you and these are
these decision cutting out on me ah so
these these decisions are these values
about I should go attack this this
person um that would be a good thing to
do those are those are sort of values
coming in but the players are bringing
with them right there's there's nothing
intrinsically about the game that would
steer them in that direction or am i
writing about that
well that depends on the game design but
the idea the entire idea of a sandbox
game sandbox is a very loose term by the
way there's a lot of debate over what it
actually means but in general they set
up the systems they set up the mechanics
you press answering sword that kind of
stuff they put the players in there and
say play okay and and generally like if
you kill someone they drop all their
gear now you can take their stuff so
there's reasons to kill people but there
also may be social reasons not to kill
people so it becomes a I think it's very
interesting I think there's if you
instilled the metrics within the design
they are amazing for sociology as long
as you don't get the observer effect
going okay but i think it's an untapped
yeah i think there's I think there's a
ton of potential there the question the
question that would be how do you
actually move forward with that you need
obviously you need people who have you
know talents and design who actually can
can you know manipulate the code and we
have a lot of experience like you're
saying before with other games and then
how do you get philosophers involved in
that or is it better to is a better baby
to leave them out and just go from you
know i don't think so i think it would
be better to least have someone on staff
an advisor at the very least someone or
at least someone with an education in
there a philosophical education on the
design team if you're if you're steering
it in that direction yeah because it
needs to be it needs to be part of the
core design and it says can't be tacked
on tap and Stefan doesn't work I mean
it's it's crap so it need to be part of
the base foundation needs to be the game
needs to be integrated yeah it's the
word i was searching for other other
companies that are that are doing that
sort of thing that are looking to you
know it wouldn't necessarily have to be
somebody in philosophy you'd think
people in the humanities more generally
you
historians are great at doing this kind
of thinking as well about you know
motives and means and ends political
scientists some literature people
perhaps again I can't say offhand I'm
fairly certain that a blizzard
entertainment the makers of world of
warcraft they have brought on
psychologists and such to help designer
game which is actually kind of dirty
they made a very addicting like skinner
box type stuff man i'm not kidding and
uh that's that's alleged though I I'm
not saying that was certainly people can
do their own research on that um bi it's
that there's some shady stuff there's a
reason water Warcraft holds like seventy
percent of the market you know in
education there's this big push to like
you know do gamification and by
gamification they mean things like
awarding badges or or giving out actual
like if you make it to all the class
periods you get these cards or you know
things along all variants powers and
levels and yeah it's all it's it's very
dirty low level psychology tricks and
it's in my eyes that's the whole idea on
the end on the ed theory part is that
you're gonna incorporate what's
addicting about games to education
because education isn't a dick big
enough so I mean that that that's its
own entire discussion as for whether
that's okay or not and do the ends
justify the means that's its own little
um I think gamification is useful I
think it has I think gamification is
comic training wheels um it's it's good
for getting people started but people do
need to develop the skills to go out on
their own and to have their own
determination so yeah they can't run why
on that so that brings up a really good
question that maybe we could since where
we've been on for about an hour we could
close with by getting your take on so if
it is training wheels sooner or later
you got to take the training wheels a
lot and if gaming you
is something that we could use as
educators to bring people in how then do
we get them out of the game and doing
you know the other activities that we
really want them involved how do we
avoid the danger of them saying now that
the game is a hell of a lot more other
this education stuff I think games are
your gateway drug to higher education
there you're there you're hey check this
out yeah great Bob this out I think that
that's least the way I view it like
that's how it worked with me from game
bioshock it got because the game was
heavily influenced by the writings vine
r and i was in high school I no idea who
I grant was and then I like heard it
mentioned in a review or something I was
like okay I'll go check it out because I
really like the game and then it got me
hooked on it end up reading Atlas
Shrugged Fountainhead all that which was
a little bit dangerous for youth
isolated from philosophy to only be
reading Iran but it was nice it was it
was good intro I never would have gotten
into philosophy at all if it weren't for
that one game yeah most likely that's
that's the key thing is um you know like
you said a gateway drug although we
probably want to avoid the word drug
business so the Miss marketing term but
yeah gateway experience perhaps or
something like yeah yeah you know a lot
of people they here's a problem that
often comes up people will say this
can't be a solution because it only goes
this far and we want this stuff over
here and so long as you know the end
part of this actually remains open so
you can get past then it seems seems
okay like I you're right i wouldn't i
wouldn't give aunt iran to anybody to
read for you know a full history of
philosophy because she gets you know a
lot of the history of philosophy
actually wrong but if it gets somebody
started and interested in more
philosophy then i say great you know
that that's that's a
exactly what we want you know so yeah a
lot lot to think about here do you have
any other any other questions for me or
ideas that you want to put forward or
hundreds but for now I i do want to do
something I want I'm gonna give you a
game that I want you to play ok if it's
fit injure there's a free version of it
but there's also a paid version fifteen
dollars I think you'll really enjoy it
and I want you to give me a book to read
oh ok so the game the game I want you to
play i'll throw you a link in an email
after this it's called the stanley
parable Stanley's like Stanley Cup same
spelling yeah yeah okay Stanley parable
and you take your time if you want ok
well um what hit I mean you've read so
you've read some some hydro and what
else do you read in philosophy really
nothing else um how much time do you
have that's good because before I
suggest like what I will be a copious
amounts okay well then you know what I
would you know what I would actually say
let's start with is uh plato's republic
and i would i would just give a couple
guidelines for like a first-time read in
doing that one is that first of all the
translations that we have out there are
kind of oxford e so you got to get past
some of the verbiage a little bit but if
you read it and reread it there's a lot
going on in every passage and Socrates
is from from chapter to chapter they
call them books because it used to be
scrolls you know instead of chapters in
codex's but from from book to book he's
developing all these different theories
about
human nature about our personality if
the word soul trips you up just just
substitute personality in there yes
generally when I do anyway but okay yeah
and then you know he's talking about the
city and he's laying out kind of an
ideal city he's not actually proposing
that as like you know here's what we're
actually going to do in real life he's
using it as kind of a hazy model against
which we can we can measure other things
and so you want to keep all of that in
mind and he'll seem to be like straying
from topic to topic to topic because
Plato's really good that way he's an
artist he's great at misdirecting you so
it takes a couple reads before you fully
get what's going on in the book but it's
it's one that's really central to
philosophy it raises some key issues
about you know about ethics but also
about appearance and reality gives you a
lot of cool the images that you know or
fun to think about and a lot of other
people later on are going to be there
either going to be reacting to it or
they're going to be incorporating parts
of it or they're going to be you know
totally disagreeing with it so it's good
it's a good piece to know because it's
sort of like having a landmark you know
it's like Greek philosophy 101 yeah yeah
and it's and it's a difficult work don't
get me wrong so so one of the things i
would say too I actually tell all my
students is in class let read bits of it
don't get discouraged you know if you're
not getting everything right away I'm
I've been reading Plato's Republic for
at least 25 years and each time that I
go through it I still find some things
that I messed because it's that it's
that rich it so you know I've been
talking to a gamer and the game designer
I this is this actually works out really
well think about a really well-designed
game that has all sorts of you know cool
features that you have to unlock and you
don't even know that you need to unlock
them yet that's the way the Republic is
alright so that's cool I'm going to
check it out okay maybe down the line
you know it'd be fun to continue this I
do this doctor say on their philosophy
forum I've been doing it monthly and
bringing I started bringing on guests
and i'm going to start stepping it up
down the line and doing it more than
monthly if you want to be a guest on
that we could do another one of these
conversations and talk about philosophy
game design that could be a lot of fun i
enjoyed this i look forward to it okay
well sounds good alright so um this is
zachary taylor up do you want to put in
a plug before we've met not yet Oh Kenny
might leave my first appearance
untarnished all right no no profit
motive no no hidden agendas or anything
like that so we've been discussing game
design and philosophy and how these
might come together do you want to have
the last word or um not enough one to
all my academic brothers and sisters
whenever you approach any form of our FB
a painting book art movie always
remember that no matter how trivial or
silly it seems there's always something
that can be learned from it it's a good
sense about the clothes on all right
we'll have a good day and this is a
really good conversation I joined it